wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn what
entrepreneurial legends think about elon
musk
elon musk has built a great electric car
he's
designed and built reusable rockets he's
an innovator in
tunneling technology bill you knew
steve jobs relatively well microsoft
competed vigorously with apple microsoft
when you were ceo was invest was an
investor
in apple
people have described elon musk as the
new steve jobs is he the new steve jobs
i you know if you know people personally
then that kind of gross over
simplification uh
it seems strange
you know elon's more of a hands-on
engineer steve was a genius at design
and picking people and marketing you
wouldn't walk into a room and confuse
them with each other the
fact that elon musk and others
did a great electric car
is a huge contribution
uh to the climate change effort you know
that he did it with quality it's still a
little premium priced but fine uh you
know he's got that initial market and
that market's going to grow and all the
other car companies seeing his success
will come in up next is warren buffett
what do you think of elon musk though if
you met him and would you invest in
tesla
well i think you're trying to bait me a
little i don't know i'm just asking you
because i know
have you met him oh yeah he joined the
giving flight some years ago that only
met him once or twice yeah that's a i've
talked with him but not for quite a
while and would you invest in tesla no
do you even know elon musk i've never
i've never said anything negative about
england i mean you know you're baiting
me a little bit to do it but i am but uh
but
i've never you know i i people like his
car and everything but uh
uh
but did somebody mention that now he's
talking about financing
something this morning about that i i i
thought i heard that earlier yes well
actually
andrew just read some headlines where it
looked like they may be tesla may be
going back to market and to to pick up
some additional financing i'm not
entirely sure all i hear was that all i
heard was the headline that's what i
call a counter revelation i mean charlie
you know because i think it was just a
few days ago they said they wouldn't
need financing
it but
you know he's he's trying something to
improve a product and i salute him for
that up next jordan peterson you see
someone like elon musk i mean what the
hell do you make of someone like that
you know i mean what did he do he made
an electric car which is basically
impossible and it works which is
basically impossible and then he built
an infrastructure so that you could
charge the damn thing wherever you drove
and that was basically impossible and
then he made it cheap because if you buy
an electric car and you factor in the
price of gas the electric car is
actually
about as expensive as the gasoline car
and so that was unbelievable then he
built a bloody rocket
which was one-tenth the price or less
that of a nasa rocket that you could
reuse
which was impossible and then he put one
of his cars on top of the rocket and he
shot it up into space
and then this happened right this all
happened and he's still alive
and you know and then he went and blew
it all by smoking pot on joe rogan you
know because
because
well it's so funny you know we
you know we like our insane geniuses
like predictable and and and and safe
and so we don't want them doing strange
things like having a tiny puff of
marijuana on a show famous for marijuana
up next is richard branson first of all
tell me what you thought about the elon
musk the falcon heavy launch you must
have loved it
uh i was a little bit jealous a little
bit jealous
i i mean elon and his team are
extraordinary what they achieved and
they did well they they all did just
fantastic um competition is healthy
right
all i can say is what watch this space
and we will be coming uh with we're
coming hopefully out with
something very exciting over the next
very few months up next donald trump
tesla's now worth more than gm and ford
do you have comments on elon musk well
you have to give him credit i spoke to
him very recently and he's also doing
the rockets he likes rockets and uh he
does good at rockets too by the way i
never saw where the engines come down
with no wings no anything and they're
landing i said i've never seen that
before
and i was worried about him because he's
one of our great geniuses and we have to
protect our genius you know we have to
protect thomas edison and
we have to protect all of these people
that
came up with originally the light bulb
and the wheel and all of these things
and he's one of our
very smart people and we want to we want
to cherish those people that's very
important but he's done a very good job
shocking
how well you know how it's come so fast
i mean you go back a year
and they were talking about the end of
the company and now all of a sudden
they're talking about these great things
he's going to be building a very big
plant
in the united states he has to because
we help him so he has to help us up next
is barbara corcoran i own a tesla and
don't say anything wrong to me about
that company all right i invest in it
just yeah all you have to do is get a
tesla or borrow when i drive around and
you are sold these guys are just hedging
their bets they don't want to be rolling
their predictions so they're taking it
down a little it's all nonsense so you
guys are a winner you own a tax
absolutely i mean what about the
competition dashboard alone is enough to
just buy just if they sold me the
dashboard i'd be happy sitting at home
looking at it without wheels without
anything else just want the dashboard
yeah i mean that is the concept though
it is it is a nicely made car better
than nice it's gorgeous all right i
didn't think you'd be such a big elon
musk fan but it's really it's i'm on his
core to the company too though right
here i mean you're talking about a way
that he leads the company it is elon
musk's company it's rough but let me
tell you any great leader is rough any
great leader has a strong opinion and
isn't so smooth on the edges and drives
it home but that's what you want when
you want to reinvent a category and
that's what he's done you have to hand
it to the guy and he's good looking i
think up next charlie munger one of my
favorite lines from you is you want to
hire the guy with the iq of 130 that
thinks it's 120 and the guy with an iq
of 150 who thinks it's 170 will just
kill you you must be thinking about elon
musk what do you think about tesla
um is that company going to become a
major player
well
it's already created
more significance than anybody would
have predicted
and
its founder is
bold and brilliant
and swings for the fences and of course
people like that get some remarkable
results and sometimes they
get some quick failure
and i haven't the faintest idea how elon
musk is gonna
turn out but i think he's gotta
considerable chance of success and a
considerable chance of failure
he seems to like it that way
have you considered overnight elon musk
getting into the candy business as he
suggested he might do on twitter i
didn't hear that it sounds like
wiseassery i want to ask you about tesla
the company has a market capitalization
of about 140 billion dollars
it traded last week about 200 billion
dollars in stock and traded about 500
billion dollars in options
and the stock moved about 20 percent a
day meanwhile mr musk seems thrilled to
stoke this volatility
um i wanted to know what your thoughts
are on this situation uh and
particularly what your thoughts are on
mr musk's behavior
my thoughts are too
i would never buy it
and i would never sell short
[Applause]
i have a third comment
there's a man
found in los angeles for years named
howard ahmanson
he once said something that
i've taken to my heart
never underestimate the man who
overrestrains himself
i think elon musk is peculiar and
he may overestimate himself but he may
not be wrong all the time elon says a
conventional mode is quaint and that's
true of a bottle of water and he says
that the best moat would be to have a
big competitive position and that is
also right
you know it's a it's ridiculous up next
is steve forbes whatever you want to say
about elon musk as an entrepreneur as an
actor he also is a person who knows how
to move markets when he made disparaging
remarks on saturday night live about
dogecoin or however you pronounce the
thing that that asset collapsed or
certainly went down in value
elon musk buying bitcoin several months
ago or tesla and saying that except
bitcoin is a payment for tesla cars it's
made bitcoin a respectable vehicle or
certainly added respectability to it now
the announcement the tesla would no
longer accept bitcoin as payment sent
that to asset down several thousand
dollars in value so this is a man who
moves markets and the reason why is
because people see elon musk as the one
who looks at things with a different set
of eyes and if he sees something like
some virtue and cryptocurrencies by
golly you better take a close look at
them and re-examine if you're against
them do a re-examination up next sad
guru i'm a big fan of elon musk
and he's uh on interplanetary travel and
that's what's on the car you're also
going to marsh no not yet
i i don't have so much money
but
so he's up he's talking about evolution
of human beings he's he wants to be
buried on mars right
i think the last time we evolved was
more than 15 000 years ago and we may be
due for an update
where do you think the human race is
going to go in the next hundred or maybe
even 500 years and how do you think
we're going to upgrade how are we going
to evolve
i i don't want to comment on elon musk
well he's made a nice car
the first one that he made on the lotus
platform
yeah
so that was faster than a ferrari i
drove that one
so i have no complaints about him
but
he must restrict himself to cars maybe
airplanes maybe even a rocket
but he shouldn't talk about human
mechanism it's a different matter and
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is mark cuban talk to me
about tesla how do you view this whole
situation i look when you invest in an
entrepreneur you get the entrepreneur
and and elon is quite the entrepreneur
so how can anybody expect anything
different
and if you look at the great companies
right now with the largest market caps i
mean apple steve jobs everybody
complained at one point or another about
steve he got fired you look at amazon
everybody complained about jeff oh he
you know he's not trying to make any
money he's not giving guidance he's not
doing this he's not doing that reid
hastings the same thing you know when
when you invest in an entrepreneur you
get the personality and if that's not
appropriate if you don't think it's
right
buy another stock yeah but i mean come
on the fundamentals matter don't they i
mean whether tesla's going to go private
or not that that's at the heart of this
conversation but fundamentals it depends
where you are in your life cycle right
or their growth cycle of the company you
know if you look at the companies i just
mentioned but you know everybody
complained about amazon fundamentals
matter everybody complained about
netflix fundamentals mattered again
steve jobs got fired from apple
fundamentals matter and they brought in
john scully a traditional entrepreneur
or traditional ceo who was good at what
he did but he wasn't the guy to drive
apple to new heights they had to bring
steve back that's just the nature of
great companies these guys you know they
don't cash out like me they stay there
because they're committed and they're
dedicated and you've got to take the you
know some of the
the uniqueness of each person as as part
of what you invest in if you were a
shareholder in tesla and i don't believe
you are correct me if i am wrong
um how should shareholders though feel
about a tweet coming out saying funding
secured
the stock gets halted now what if the
deal doesn't happen
i mean look
i guess that's the way we run the
country run some companies now too but
what i would tell elon and i don't know
him at all um and i do have two teslas
by the way um i would tell them shorts
are your friends i mean you know going
back 20 years when we ran broadcast.com
you know a lot of we were like a lot of
internet companies heavily shorted and
you know the beauty of shorts is if you
have a good quarter if you do your job
then they have to buy back the stock at
some point and so i i would sit down
with them and say look rather than
getting all upset about shorts the more
people that show your stock the better
position you have the more you know the
more buyers you have in waiting and and
so i think that that's kind of the
attitude someone's got to get to him but
again this is the guy who's sleeping in
the factory this is a guy who's pushing
pushing pushing and if you go through
the list of all the companies i just
mentioned all the fangs you know maybe
with the exception of google i mean even
facebook when facebook went public then
they had the questions about mobile then
people questioned whether or not
zuckerberg can run it now facebook's
going through other issues again people
are questioning zuckerberg great
entrepreneurs who are so committed to
their companies that they are never
going to leave they want to take it as
far as they can take it they are going
to be unique and and they are going to
be issues in in how they address the
public and how they address shareholders
and that's the beauty of why those
companies are so amazing and so big and
so i would tell shareholders
you know be grateful that you have
somebody that committed to the company
and and recognize that you know
being unique is what has helped make
elon and or help make tesla so
successful do you think he's taken the
shorts too seriously or or become
consumed with what short sellers have
been saying yeah it's hard not to right
when it's your baby a lot of times it's
hard not to take all that personally
it's hard not to to feel it inside of
you
you know to be a great entrepreneur
you've got to be so competitive and all
the people that i've mentioned all all
had their persnickety issues but they
were all incredibly competitive and
including elon and when you're that
competitive and people are nailing and
talking bad about your family like that
you it's hard not to respond and he's
got to learn not to respond but look it
happens to me talking about the
mavericks that happens to to a lot of
different people when when you're
criticized it's it's hard not to return
fire sometimes what about elon musk
we've been talking about him a little
bit um
genius clearly questions about uh
execution and how he's conducting
himself publicly when so much is riding
on his public image would you would you
put more uh into his companies into
tesla for example as an investor after
that last earnings call
yeah look i think he hits the nail in
the head look you know
it's okay for a ceo to have some stuff
to him or her right it's okay for them
to have an attitude you don't have to be
vanilla all the time that's his life i
mean unlike
other founders not even ceos but unlike
under other founders who have their
lives all filled up into one company
he puts his heart out there and he puts
his finances out there you know you can
respect elon musk for his genius but you
have to really respect it because he
puts every cent that he has on the line
this is not like you know what i got all
my money out
every one of these companies he puts his
own cash into and he's gone to the limit
and so look
it's his baby he sees the vision he has
to execute you can argue that he's going
to need to raise cash or this math but
his everything he has is wrapped up in
it as far as i understand it and i think
for that reason i'm not necessarily a
buyer because i don't know the industry
but you've got to trust them and i don't
think the stuff on the conference call
was anything at all that was just
michigan
[Music]
you said we need hundreds of elon musks
and with tesla's expansion in places
like china and india that's only going
to increase their carbon footprint
should tesla be more upfront about that
well tesla reduces your carbon footprint
and if they get
you know an electric car
uh as we convert the electric generation
to be zero emissions
is one of the few categories that you
know we see a path to zero now it's only
about seven percent of emissions come
from
passenger cars globally and so you can't
declare victory there but
you know as the cost of those cars comes
down the range goes up the charge points
are more numerous and standardized and
quick charging
uh
you'll you'll feel like yes a gasoline
car
less maintenance you know quieter
uh the market will eventually
take care of this and so you won't need
regulations even though they've been
used including a tax credit
to get the volume up
to get to that point and so
every category needs to go through that
process
of bringing its its green premium
down dramatically elon has in the past
claimed you shorted tesla and i wonder
if there's any truth to that
uh well
you know i think tesla's an amazing
company uh i wish i'd you know own been
more on the the
alongside but you know i mean you know
it's it's great uh
and
you know i i have lots of relatives
swollen teslas that i've uh
helped buy for them so you know nothing
but positive thoughts about tesla and
its roles wouldn't you like doing a
podcast with elon musk let's start an
initiative for this yes i would like to
do a podcast with elon musk i'd like to
ask him about his thought process and
also i'm really curious about how in the
world he manages to do multiple
impossible things because doing one
impossible thing is impossible but doing
like five impossible things is the
product of five impossibilities and that
just seems like hyper impossible but
he's managed it you know i mean think
about it think about what he did he
built an electric car
which is like hard
and then he built a rocket and then he
blasted the car into space on his rocket
like that
that's not that's not real that doesn't
happen
but it did happen and he did it and so
i would really i would love to talk to
him i think that would be extremely uh
extremely interesting because you made
it this far in a video i want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to see the
top 50 rules of success i did on ninon
mas check it out right there next to me
i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there well
first of all i'd say i actually think i
i think i feel feel fear quite strongly
um so it's not as though
i just have the absence of fear
i feel quite strongly um